don't forget him resume PAH today we're
gonna play three games because you're
welcome
saw him on this girl website but I
looked for boy games and this is what I
found
quick unhook the bra someone was like
I'm gonna make a game and it will be how
to unhook a bra in a cartoonish style on
a girly website okay
sexism in video games huh
[Music]
yes so I draw patterns I could do this
on my Android this is equally
entertaining yeah that's that's what
every girl says when you unhook their
bra what's it so what's the point what
like what what are you what for oh god
it's so complicated maybe I'll fail
there's no way you can fail well I take
that back actually I think I fail what
do you want from me
oh damn it okay so there's a time and I
didn't see that that makes it a little
bit more interesting I would say this
game is so unrealistic it's harder in
real life to do it that's all I'm saying
I'm getting this a once over know what
that fukk got a process what the actual
[ __ ] my idea right are you kidding me
what kind of parents are these what are
they gonna make me do a [ __ ] Smuts
again later or what I just I had to just
figure it out and then this [ __ ]
there we go are they at all wearing
panties it must be so cold I got it I
got it shut up I am the bun brah bread
best Jesus Jesus
damnit damnit I was so close
alright so that was quick unhook the
broth very nice game I am a zombie with
a [ __ ] nice ass shirt maybe a zombie
clown yeah the Emma clown that's it
following a little fish in and purple
hurricane let's go into the cave shall
we why don't we not please thank you
well what the [ __ ] is that octopus city
blues right of course sorry where do I
find these games alright that's a nice
cape
thank you oh gosh thumbs up please thank
you
ah thanks better somersault in there
like the little thing on his face oh
it's my evil twin mr. clowny number 2
damn it what happened to my face what
the [ __ ] notice to mean on that is
disgusting okay it's over let me just go
this way thank you ah faceplant
of course Space Princess Overlord will
save me from my face plants I've been
waiting for your cow calf [ __ ] whatever
you are the only one who can end my
suffering what about my face blind
suffering oh of course it was all a
dream
of course Lisa how you doing Lisa oh
sorry Daisy your Daisy mom or dad hard
to tell with tentacles nice I get some
sleep
sure why not if someone has any [ __ ]
clue what's going on please go ahead and
let me know anytime I'll pause it for
you how are you guys
cheer up miss having you yet yeah it's
not that bad
how could you say that everything I went
Forks card
oh sorry Henriette dad I know you were
such a [ __ ] what happened in
Henrietta's diner this place is closed
damn it I've never been so confused and
turned on at the same time okay wait
that was a nice dream what nice pictures
of creepy people cuz where are they're
not pictures of creepy people in this
game my mom I don't want to talk to her
well my life numbers getting many went
down this pipe but no one returned what
the [ __ ]
I can become Sonic this is officially
the best game ever
of course why wouldn't I be able to
become Sonic
alright I think that's enough nightmares
for about a month or two yeah that game
was great alright finally we're gonna
play yacht lhasa you're like my Yoshi
impression one day over at a peaceful
island of the Yoshi's it seemed like
something that's falling from the sky
into the deep blue ocean the Yoshi's on
the island is still organizing my bag it
was a bag of [ __ ] it must be one of the
babies I hate when they try to make a
story it's kind of like pornos it's like
can we get on with it please oh cool I
didn't know y'all she's had thumbs
bring me the spokes this shrine of wine
it sounds like my kind of plays if you
know what I'm if you know what I'm
saying
sorry I just had a Lola it's in my face
if I could play that'd be great big fan
of playing video games if I didn't want
to play a video game I played the rest
sir come on unwitting please oh look at
me I'm a yashi [ __ ] I'm a yah-tchi
I'm a Joshi look at those mountain tits
girl oh my gosh gee I'm a Yoshi [ __ ]
I'm a Yoshi
it starts off cute and fluffy I've seen
this before the twist Oh cat couldn't
even finish my sentence huh there we go
apparently I have a string in
in my ass ow uh-oh it's not the vehicle
of why is it so [ __ ] zoomed in of Jeb
flatterfit dance ballet alright then
someone someone did that good for you
I'm gonna keep helping whoever it calls
for help
see I have a purpose what was that
you can play that game look yeah now you
see me now you don't don't [ __ ]
oh Jesus I better start tap-dancing that
was real scary
alright oh boy so scared this is the
scariest game are you scared yet breaths
oh boy I'm scared I'm Yoshi I'm scared
as [ __ ]
actually he look more like I'm high it's
[ __ ] where the [ __ ] is it out crying
it's baby son of a [ __ ] when I get my
hands on you I'm gonna spank that booty
taeju's bye son do you hear the people
sing singing the song of Angry Men it is
a people love music oh now this Yoshi
again when the beating of my heart
echoes the beating of what the [ __ ] was
that I'm done don't know yashi anymore
sorry I say okay this morning I've seen
in my life I'm not I let some ugly
[ __ ] ride me but I'm not gonna let
that one ride me all right I don't care
for my Yoshi is it over yeah she why did
you do it you know I'm gonna send my
feed back to that one well I was
probably the best game I ever played I
don't know by hubris but I would rate it
probably a million dollar signs in
Australia yeah yeah but anyway if you
enjoyed this video hit that like button
as always stay awesome